not macht erfinderisch dieses sprichwort
muss für den bundeshaushalt erfunden
worden sein alle jahre wieder die
gleiche performance um politische
leidenschaften zu befrieden muss geld
beschafft werden kredite
schattenhaushalte luftbuchungen die
trickkiste ist randvoll dabei ist in
diesem jahr die lage wirklich ernst
krieg corona klima woher soll das geld
kommen jetzt in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst im studio ist otto fricke der
haushaltspolitische sprecher der
fdp-bundestagsfraktion in gleicher
funktion bei cdu/csu im bundestag also
haushaltspolitischer sprecher christian
haase zugeschaltet sind und hermann
wirtschaftsjournalistin bei der taz der
tageszeitung und
reiner holznagel der präsident des
bundes der steuerzahler
die ausgaben die laufende ampelkoalition
davon wir haben eine schuldenbremse ohne
bremsklötze bei schwarzer null fragen
sich manche was war das eigentlich noch
so haben sie sich ja eigentlich die
regierungsbeteiligung nicht vorgestellt
erlebt die fdp gerade so etwas wie eine
schocktherapie nein sie erlebt das was
reale politik ist und was haushälter die
jetzt seit 2002 haus ausfindig machen
immer wieder erlebt haben allerdings
nicht in dem extremen maße wie es jetzt
gegenwärtig ist und ich muss auch ganz
klar sagen jetzt mal unabhängig von der
besonderheit der ukraine krise vieles
davon wussten wir dass dann auch noch
das hatten wir befürchtet die inflation
dazu kommt macht das ganze nicht
angenehm aber ich sag mal auch so
schönwetterpolitik kann jeder dann
brauche ich keine neuen regierung wie
war es mit coco so bequem in der ära
merkel konnte man ja noch aus dem vollen
aus dem vollen des
steuerschecks geschöpft werden sind sie
froh jetzt in der opposition gelandet zu
sein
das kann man nicht sagen also man ist
nie froh in der opposition auch wir
würden jetzt die herausforderung
annehmen die die zeit bietet das haben
wir in den letzten zwei jahren corona
gehabt das setzt sich jetzt in diesem
haushalt vor wird noch durch die durch
den putin krieg getoppt also nein wir
hätten die variiert vorher man erst
hatten wir kein glück und dann kam noch
pech dazu kann denn die ampel koalition
ihre politischen projekte angesichts der
aktuellen lage erst mal vergessen
naja also ein wesentlicher teil der des
projektes war ja dass man auch die
erneuerbaren energien ausbaut und ich
glaube das hat jetzt jeder gesehen dass
man sich unbedingt unabhängig machen
muss von dem russischen gas und den
zwischen öl also ich glaube eigentlich
dass die projekte der ampel sogar noch
einen schub bekommen haben nicht man
muss es natürlich mit schulden
finanzieren das ist ja das was jetzt
auch gerade strittig diskutiert wird
aber die ziele selbst sind glaube ich er
weiterhin im fokus
holznagel der bund der steuerzahler ist
sicherlich hoch erfreut dass ihnen die
arbeit nicht ausgeht aber in der
finanzpolitik kann man ja im moment
eigentlich nur fehler machen
na ja wir wissen noch gar nicht wie
viele fehler und wie groß die fehler
sind die im haushaltsentwurf den wir
jetzt kennen der ist ja eigentlich schon
makulatur christian lindner hat vor dem
bundestag auch noch mal deutlich gemacht
dass wird einen ergänzungs haushalt
geben da werden wir dann genau sehen was
passiert ist jedenfalls wir gehen noch
einmal massiv in die neuverschuldung und
sagte es eben auch dass an vielen
stellen einfach so weitergemacht wird
als wenn es keine krise gibt als wenn es
keinen krieg gibt also insofern haben
sie recht es werden viele fehler gemacht
gut in der heutigen generaldebatte ist
ja da auch einiges genannt worten den
finger in die wunde legen muss ja immer
der oppositionsführer das ist der
fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu/csu
friedrich merz das hat er heute auch
gemacht mit einer äußerung zum
bundeshaushalt und die wollen wir uns
mal ganz kurz ansehen die
steuereinnahmen werden vermutlich
deutlich niedriger ausfallen als
erwartet und vor allem die ausgaben
werden durch den ukrainer krieg und alle
seine folgen deutlich steigen das wissen
wir alle dass wissen auch sie sprechen
beschönigend und einem ergänzungs
haushalt den sie wahrscheinlich schon im
nächsten monat vorliegen müssen und zwar
in einer größenordnung von bis zu 50
milliarden euro und trotzdem legen sie
in dieser woche einen bundeshaushalt vor
so als ob nichts gewesen wäre
dieser haushalt herr verkauf und 2022
der ist jetzt schon makulatur in der tat
gibt es ja noch einen nachtragshaushalt
wären wir gleich noch drüber reden
kann man im moment nur auf sicht fahren
worauf müssen uns eigentlich anstellen
ja man kann auf sicht fahren neben
keiner von uns weiß wie das in der
ukraine weitergeht wir haben unsere
hoffnungen aber davon darf sich ein
haushälter nie treiben lassen wir müssen
aber jetzt und deswegen war auch die
aussage von herrn merz einfach
schlichtweg nicht ganz so fair der
ergänzungs haushalt ist genau das mittel
was man macht wenn während eines
haushalts verfahrens wohl noch nicht das
parlament abgeschlossen hat die
regierung erkennt wir müssen anpassen
das noch nicht genau weiß dann aber
innerhalb sich berät und dann den
ergänzungs haushalt in das
haushaltsverfahren das bereits läuft
einbringt ist auch keine neue sache ich
habe das jetzt auch heute noch meinem im
plenum gesagt franz josef strauß hat das
bereits 1967 gemacht der grund ist dass
die bundeshaushaltsordnung das
ausdrücklich vorsieht die alternative
wäre gewesen da friedrich merz wir
machen erstmal keinen haushalt machen
vorläufiger haushaltsführung und hätten
dann übrigens von ihm gehört naja warum
liegt ja eigentlich noch keinen haushalt
vor haushalt heißt bei sich verändernden
bedingungen stetige anpassung notfalls
auch nachtragshaushalte so wie es die
große koalition wegen corona machen
musste so wie wir es jetzt mit einem
ergänzungs haushalt machen müssen wegen
der ukraine krise jetzt sind ja eine
ganze menge von unklarheiten noch was
die ausgaben angeht es gerade schon
angeklungen es geht um die folgen des
krieges das sind enorme energiekosten
die abgefedert werden sollen sozial
abgefedert werden sollen wir haben das
noch nicht wie viel geld wir für die
ukrainischen flüchtlinge hier in
deutschland aufwenden müssen das ist
eine sehr sehr hohe summe auch
humanitäre unterstützung für die ukraine
selbst das sondervermögen bundeswehr
lassen aber noch außen vor da kommen wir
später dazu mit welchen summen rechnen
sie dann noch draufkommen im moment ist
die neuverschuldung ja bei 99,7
milliarden also ich wage mal die
prognose
das hat ja auch herr merz gesagt dann
nochmal 50 milliarden es ist aber im
augenblick nicht gegriffen zahl also die
koalition untätigkeit zum beispiel diese
woche um das thema entlastung bei
energiekosten entlastung bei den
benzinkosten da weiß ich nicht welche
größenordnung letztendlich die regierung
sieht wir haben ja auch schon 150
milliarden zusätzlicher kosten gehört
dass es dann zusammen sich subsumiert
auf eine aber dritten billionen aber
genau das ist ja die gefahr wenn man
einmal sieht da ist der schulden tor
offen dass man dann die grenze nicht
sieht wenn wir jetzt sagen würden wir
konnten uns noch 20 milliarden leisten
dann würde man wahrscheinlich auch in
dieser range bleiben jetzt natürlich die
wünsche die forderung an politik immens
groß weil man sieht naja irgendwie ist
keine zumindestens erkennen ihre grenzen
da hätte zum beispiel jetzt eine ansage
des kanzlers da hat er ja an anderer
stelle auch gemacht oder des
bundesfinanzministers gesagt also wir
sind einmalig bereit nochmal 40 noch mal
20 nochmal 30 zur verfügung zu stellen
immer mit der frage kann ich das dann im
politischen prozess auch halten das ist
schwierig das kann ich nachvollziehen da
jetzt irgend eine zahl zu sagen muss ist
ja gucken welche maßnahme wirkt denn am
ende wo können wir entlasten wie lange
dauern überhaupt die mehrleistung
vielleicht in drei monaten die
spritpreise wieder unten und wir haben
eine temporäre maßnahme
und es kostet vielleicht nur die hälfte
von dem was wir heute haben also es ist
sehr schwierig im augenblick zu sagen
deswegen die die frage von ergänzungs
haushalt ist ja auch die frage wann
werden wir als parlament damit
konfrontiert dann haben wir endlich mal
zahlen auf dem tisch also ich bin eher
ein freund davon zu sagen je später wir
klare zahlen haben wenn wir jetzt erst
auf ende april anfang mai kommen wir
wollen ja ende mai auch den haushalt
dann irgendwie abschließen dann lieber
warten und im sommer für einen
nachtragshaushalt in dem wir uns
beschäftigen sie haben ja vorhin schon
die
haushaltspositionen was den klimaschutz
angeht was man sich da vorgenommen hat
genannt was jetzt da noch dazu kommt
diese kosten die ja noch nicht so
richtig zu beziffern sind sind das alles
notwendige kosten gerade was die
folgendes ukraine krieges angeht was die
energiekosten angeht glauben sie dass
wir tatsächlich diese diese ausgaben
alle brauchen oder ist da auch einiges
an überflüssigen dabei
na ja also ich bin nicht dafür dass man
ganz normale bürger entlastet reiche
bürger entlastet die eigentlich diese
höheren energiekosten er selber tragen
können also dieses prinzip dies kann er
das bei herrn lindner zu erkennen ist
das irgendwie jeder entlastet wird der
auto fährt das finde ich falsch also ich
fände es besser wenn man die knappen
mittel das hat herr hase ja völlig
richtig dargestellt man kann nicht
beliebig viel geld ausgeben dann sollte
man aber die knappen mittel dorthin
lenken wo sie wirklich gebraucht werden
also vor allen dingen bei
geringverdienern sie nicht in der lage
sind diese hohen energiepreise
abzufedern aber das irgendwie alle in
deutschland bedient werden müssen das
ist ja das prinzip der fdp das finde ich
ganz frisch
möglicherweise meint sich jetzt den tank
rabatt
heutzutage gehen sie ja glaube ich ganz
gut finden wenn ich das gelesen habe
aber ist es ja im prinzip auch etwas was
nach dem gießkannenprinzip geht da wird
jeder bedacht der auto fährt sogar
besonders gut bedacht und ein bisschen
mehr gas gibt bei mobilitäts geld das
ist die spd-opposition da kriegt jeder
wenn er eine bestimmte einkommensgrenze
nicht überschreitet geld egal ob ein
auto hat oder nicht was ist da das
sinnvollste um bleiben wir bei diesem
thema energiekosten dass er die meisten
im moment am meisten oder wichtigsten
auch beschäftigt was ist das sinnvoll wo
sollte der
der gesetzgeber da besonders geld
ausgeben
also wir müssen die diskussion ein wenig
sortieren wir haben schon anfang des
jahres gesagt dass wir eine entlastung
beim strompreis brauchen und hier waren
unsere vorschläge eindeutig und klar das
heißt die mehrwertsteuer auf sieben
prozent bei strom ist lebensnotwendig
die energie steuer und in diesem fall
ist es die stromsteuer auf 1 cent pro
kilowattstunde das ist das mindeste
europäisch zulässig ist und am ende die
abschaffung der lage das hätte den
strompreis massiv belastet und um das
nochmal klarzustellen wir kompensieren
ja am ende nur dass die co2 besteuerung
sorgt ja dafür dass der endverbraucher
mehr zu zahlen hat und das start an
dieser stelle auch mehreinnahmen hat bei
den treibstoffen sich so ein wenig
anders und da haben wir nicht juhu
geschrieben als christian lindner den
tank rabatt vorgestellt hat ich habe
immer gesagt das ist kurzfristig eine
maßnahme um die steuer mehreinnahmen an
der tankstelle auch sofort wieder
zurückzugeben aber es muss eben auch
daran gearbeitet werden wie wir an
dieser stelle entlasten und da hatte ich
ein einfaches rezept nämlich die
entfernungspauschale
maßgerecht anzuheben dann würde man eben
auch die arbeitnehmer an dieser stelle
entlasten aber ich will es auch deutlich
sagen der staat kann nicht jede
preisspitze an dieser stelle abfedern
die preise sind hoch und wir müssen dann
eben auch mal auf die ölgesellschaften
schauen die nicht immer preissenkungen
gleich weitergeben und deswegen müssen
wir aufpassen dass der staat hier nicht
über kommt zensiert da gibt da in dem
zusammenhang wird ja auch immer herr
fricke gesagt dass man diese profite der
konzerne abschöpfen könnte und dass dann
eben entsprechend damit ausgleicht oder
in den ausgleich gibt eine entlastung
für den verbraucher ist das sinnvoll
glauben sie dass das kommt dass man da
eingreifen kann um eben gewinne
abzuschöpfen die ja möglicherweise oder
ziemlich sicher sogar auf rein
spekulativer basis entstanden sind und
nicht weil angebotsverknappung bestehen
ja also erstmal ist würde unser
marktwirtschaftliches system erst mal
nicht entsprechend an der stelle muss
ich sagen sondern dann sind wir im
kartellrecht da muss ganz klar mit
kartellstrafen gaben da ist auch etwas
wo ich das kartellamt stärke denn was
machen wir denn dann eigentlich wenn wir
mal dann nachgewiesen durch diese
unternehmen haben dass sie unterhalb des
preis verkaufen weil sie eine
kalkulation haben um sich am markt auch
durch unsere preise zu halten geben wir
dann ein zuschuss also ich bin da sehr
vorsichtig ich möchte noch mal was zu
dem tank rabatt sagen das entscheidende
was wir in deutschland in einer sozialen
marktwirtschaft sehen müssen ist beim
thema energie wir haben bei der
grundsicherung also bei hartz4 bei
grundsicherung im alter grund sich in
der pflege haben wir die kosten der
unterkunft findet eine automatische
anpassen kosten statt wir haben dann für
die nächste gruppe der wohngeldempfänger
derjenigen die bafög bekommen und
diejenigen in der ausbildung staatlich
unterziehen wir haben wir jetzt erst
gerade in der koalition beschlossen noch
mal um sogar verdoppelung gegenüber dem
versprechen planten die zuschüsse zu
erhöhen und jetzt müssen wir genau sehen
und das ist die diskussion wie treffe
ich entweder zielgenau das dauert lang
und wird kompliziert und mit den
üblichen problemen oder und das war und
das halte ich immer noch für einen guten
ansatz zu sagen die alternative ist erst
einmal nichts tun das haben wir beim
thema tanken gehabt wenn dann der
vorschlag ist wie krieges innerhalb
kürzester zeit schnell dann ist der tank
rabatt für kurze zeit nicht auf dauer
das war auch nicht geplant das richtige
nur das muss man auch ehrlich sagen wir
sind in einer koalition hier ist der
vorschlag von christian lindner wir
einen kurzen schnell etwas tun kann mit
den ungenauigkeiten gebe ich genau recht
natürlich das würde auch jemandem wie
mir helfen aber die alternative ist erst
einmal nichts zu tun und letzte sache
das problem ist wenn ich so wie die
entfernungspauschale machen wo ich auch
nach fini tät für habe habe ich
natürlich das problem was mache ich mit
dem 60 jährigen der seine 85-jährige
mutter pflegt und jeden tag hin und her
fährt und das nicht unbedingt absetzen
kann ich habe immer ungenauigkeiten da
muss ich als politik immer abwägen und
das ist nicht einfach und dann kommt die
frage hätte ich jedem helfe ich vielen
häufig wenigen und wie heftig am
genauesten das ist politik dann und da
kann man diskutieren also ich möchte
noch mal eine lanze auch wir haben guten
vorschlag gemacht glaube ich mit der
mineralölsteuern ob das jetzt in der
regierung gesagt aber zum absenken
mineralische aber wenn bin ich auch bei
dem thema tank rabatt das fand ich für
das klügste was ich gehört warum ich
komme aus dem ländlichen raum also ich
habe heute noch ein anruf gehabt von mir
eine frau erzählt hat dass sie jeden
morgen ihren mann zur arbeit bringen
muss anschließend selbst zur arbeit
fährt 160 kilometer jeden tag sagt er
also immer lohnt es sich nicht mehr zu
arbeiten und das ist doch glaube ich
gerade eine zielgruppe die wir viel
stärker in den blick nehmen müssen die
vielleicht mit ihrer arbeit nicht weit
von sozialsystemen auch weg sind aber
trotzdem sagen für uns das wichtigste
tag arbeiten zu gehen und im ländlichen
raum kann ich das nicht substituieren
und sagen ich hätte ich mich jetzt in
pnv das geht nicht und ich glaube dieser
tank rabatt wäre dann noch am ehesten
ein signal auch das start ist an diesem
menschen zu sagen wir haben verstanden
und ich fand es dann auch noch relativ
unbürokratisch in der zweiten ebene für
den tankstellen ist da vielleicht nicht
aber für mich als bürger war das
eigentlich erst mal ein vorschlag für
den ich persönlich sympathien hege wenn
man halt nicht über die steuerfrage
gehen können haben wenn man jetzt darf
sehr viele milliarden in die hand nimmt
für zuschüsse um die energiekosten
niedrig zu halten könnte das ein fass
ohne boden werden wir wissen ja gar
nicht wie sich die energiekosten
entwickeln
putin hat ja heute bekannt gegeben dass
man die öl- und gaslieferungen noch in
rubel bezahlen darf das bedeutet dass
man wieder mit der russischen notenbank
verkehren muss sozusagen das läuft dann
darüber damit der die sanktionen
unterlaufen möglicherweise zwingt das
den westen dann tatsächlich um die
sanktionen aufrechtzuerhalten von sich
aus ein öl und gas embargo gegen
russland zu erlassen also von sich aus
zu sagen wir beziehen von euch nichts
mehr das würde wahrscheinlich
kurzfristig die preise wieder nach weit
noch weiter nach oben treiben ist das
besteht die gefahr das ist ein fass ohne
boden wird
also um jetzt mal erst mal zu der sache
mit den rubel zu kommen das war eine
schlaue maßnahmen davon
putin aber das ist jetzt nicht kriegen
es entscheidend und ändert eigentlich
auch nichts an der lage an den
gasmärkten also
was putin gemacht hat mit dieser
maßnahme ist dass künftig festlegen kann
welches welchem wechselkurs ist zwischen
rubel und dollar gibt das hatten sie ja
angedeutet jetzt müssen die
westlichen
importeure von gas sich erstmal google
beschaffen das geht praktisch nur bei
der zentralbank und damit hat dann putin
die möglichkeit den wechselkurs
festzulegen
ich nehme aber an dass putin den
wechselkurs jetzt nicht astronomisch
irgendwo in welche in absurde höhen
treiben wird sondern dass er sich ein
kurs wird wie er vor dem ukraine krieg
galt das heißt dass gas wird jetzt nicht
unbedingt teurer für den westen also das
dauert jetzt noch eine woche bis putin
sich überlegt hat wie der kurs sein soll
zwischen rubel und euro und dann wird
man ja sehen ob er die idee hat den
westen zu schröpfen oder ob es nur darum
geht symbolisch zu zeigen dass irgendwie
russland noch wichtig ist in
ökonomischer hinsicht also nochmal zur
korrektur die sanktionen des westens
haben die gaslieferung nie getroffen man
hat das genauso gemacht dass die swift
sanktionen also die sanktionen zwischen
den banken
die banken ausgenommen haben in russland
die man braucht um die gaslieferungen zu
bezahlen das heißt eigentlich ändert
sich erst mal durch diese ganze aktion
von putin gar nichts außer wie gesagt
dass er jetzt künftig festlegen kann wie
der wechselkurs zwischen euro und rubel
ist aber wie gesagt ich glaube er wird
nicht übertreiben denn er will ja
weiterhin gas liefern gut
wie wird sich der gaspreis
gaspreis entwickeln weltweit also was
natürlich alarmierend ist ist und da
waren ja alle dabei das schon vor dem
ukraine krieg gas und öl immer teurer
geworden sind das heißt wir haben es
hier mit einer strukturellen veränderung
auf den energiemärkten zu tun die die
ukraine krise verschärft hat aber die
auch schon vor der ukraine krise da war
er das muss allen westeuropäer klar sein
öl und gas werden knapp die nachfrage
ist genauso hoch wie das angebot da ist
gar keine lücke mehr und das führt dazu
dass die opec also das kartell der
innenstadt letztlich festlegen kann wie
hoch der ölpreis ist und der einzige weg
raus aus dieser falle dass wir praktisch
das gesamte öl abnehmen dass es gibt ist
dass wir sparen nicht wir müssen weg von
den von der energieverschwendung wir
müssen energie sparen wir müssen auch
erneuerbare energien ausbauen sonst das
muss einem klar sein werden wir von den
opec kartellen wirklich geschätzt denn
im unterschied zu früher ist es so dass
das opec kartell jetzt funktioniert
nicht also diese hoffnung und dann
zerstreiten die sich alle diese länder
und dann verschieben sie ihr öl auf den
weltmärkten diese zeiten sind für immer
vorbei wo diese darauf muss man sich
einstellen jetzt muss natürlich sagen
dass energiewende und auch
energieeffizienz natürlich noch mit
einer zeitlichen verzögerung erst
wirklich wirksam werden können holztage
wenn sie sich jetzt die ganzen projekte
ansehen die heute auch im bundestag eine
rolle gespielt hat wofür jetzt der staat
geld in die hand nehmen muss glauben sie
dass das wirklich ohne steuererhöhungen
ab gehen kann
das wird darauf ankommen wie der
bundeshaushalt insgesamt aufgestellt
wird was wir inhalt nicht sehen ist wo
gespart werden soll wo auch die häuser
weniger zur verfügung bekommen also geld
weniger ausgeben können und das wird die
entscheidende gretchenfrage sein ich bin
auch bei frau herrmann wir müssen viele
projekte glaube ich jetzt vorantreiben
insbesondere was klimaschutz angeht was
energiewende angeht das ist gar keine
frage aber weil das eben sehr viel
priorität jetzt genießen muss müssen wir
auch definieren was des priorität ist
also wo können wir sozusagen auch geld
heben was wir dann an anderer stelle
einsetzen können mein eindruck ist so
dass die bundesregierung eigentlich so
weiter die vorher dass es überhaupt
keine prioritätensetzung gibt dass die
häuser weiterhin mit denen planen als
wenn es keine ukraine krise gibt oder
kein krieg oder auch keine krone krise
gab und dementsprechend werden auch
weitere ausgaben getätigt wo wir denn
uns auch fragen müssen ist das jetzt
noch zeit gewesen deswegen wird es
darauf ankommen inwieweit jetzt die
bundesregierung prioritäten setzt ich
hoffe dass christian hinten an den
haushalt noch einmal nachgeschärft und
darüber hinaus werden die eben auch
sehen ob die versprechungen zur
einhaltung der schuldenbremse auf
wirklich in die tat umgesetzt werden das
wird dann der angriff seien und der
bewährungs haushalt mit den nächsten
jahren stattfinden steuererhöhungen ist
ja der herr sei bei uns der fdp können
sie das ausschließen und da man kann
ihnen nichts ausschließen der politik
das ist so die typische fragen politiker
können sie auch nein da sage ich immer
ganz unterschiedliche leute ja antworte
ich schließe nichts aus wenn die frage
aber ist wird die fdp einer
steuererhöhung zustimmen dann kann ich
sagen das sehe ich nicht so das ist auch
ganz klar und zwar auch deswegen weil
und da gebe ich ein holznagel recht es
ist wie immer so du hast immer nur mehr
drei möglichkeiten steuern erhöhen
verschuldung erhöhen ausgaben kürzen in
einer guten weg würden viele sagen ja
alles drei irgendwo und der haushalt
wird noch besser in der realen welt ist
es aber so dass bei jeder ebene eine
ebene sagten die bitte bei mir nicht und
wenn sie mich jetzt gefragt hätten ob
ich den glücklich gewesen bin damit
wieder haushalt jetzt aussehen sage ich
im grundsatz ja aber ist genau das was
da gesagt dass man sich die frage stellt
auch fast kann ich auf was soll ich und
auf was muss ich verzichten das hat mich
schon geärgert dass das zu wenig ihnen
hat der ministerien gestellt aber das
ist ein problem das in der struktur
unseres staates liegt wo jede sache die
wir machen gut ist und weil sie einmal
gut war auch gut bleibt und das ist das
ist das hauptproblem und wenn dann so
haushalt dass ich jetzt über die
parteigrenzen hinweg egal ob in der
opposition oder eine koalition sind dann
sagen vielleicht könnten wir da mal
verzichten oder ich sage jetzt einen
ganz riskanten satz ist es dem wirklich
richtig dass wir fünf prozent rentner
ich weiß jetzt kriege ich sofort die e
mails ganz schlimm dann kriegen sie und
ich habe nicht gesagt dass ich das für
falsch aber nur wenn sie das schon sagen
kommt nein nein aber da auf keinen fall
kultur auf keinen fall verteidigung
aktuell keinen fall
da haben sie immer das problem und damit
müssen sie eben als haushälter kämpfen
sie werden nie beliebt sein das ist
unser schicksal aber sie müssen eben
ständig dran gehen aber deswegen
nochmals ukraine krieg und pandemie
nicht unbedingt etwas zu tun politischen
wanderprediger dann hört man ja immer
ganz gern zu in diese gruppierung gehört
sicherlich auch christian lindner in der
finanzminister der jetzt gesagt ab dem
nächsten jahr wird die schuldenbremse
wieder eingehalten glauben sie ihm
naja es ist eine herkulesaufgabe und
wenn ich höre was jetzt schon für
diskussionen innerhalb der koalition
sind also welche ansagen von
verschiedenen richtungen gemacht werden
hab ich natürlich große sorge dass er
das nicht halten kann ich selbst glaube
ich dass das machen willst ja ich habe
über die aufstellung des haushalts
gewesen wo er dann ganz geschockt ende
des jahres gesehen hat was in die
ministerien vorgeschlagen haben das ist
ja dann halte an der stelle
durchgesickert und es war jetzt glaube
ich für ihn sehr schwierig das bis zum
sommer hin zu kriegen aber kann es aber
immerhin geschafft ich will aber will
aber schon sagen doch die schuld die die
schulden schraube die ist überdreht
jetzt wir haben bedingt durch äußere
anlässe durch die korona pandemie in
drei haushaltsjahren jetzt kommt noch
mal die ukraine krise dazu wir haben in
europa schulden aufgenommen die wir
irgendwann wieder zurückzahlen müssen
und wir wissen ganz genau das was wir
jetzt an schulden aufnehmen sind ja die
steuern von morgen für unsere kinder und
kindeskinder ist seitdem wir wachsen in
einem maße wie wir uns das im augenblick
nicht vorstellen können also müssen wir
doch die schwere aufgabe der
haushaltskonsolidierung in irgendeiner
form angehen dass die koalition im
übrigen jahr angelegt das ist jetzt
nicht so dass sie sich dazu gar keine
gedanken gemacht hätte aber davon haben
wir in diesem haushalt zumindest noch
nicht viel gespürt wir sind mal so
durchgegangen wir haben so 300
finanzwirksame ausgaben gefundenen
koalitionsvertrag die sind überwiegend
noch gar nicht drin sie sind noch
außerhalb so sagen die altschulden
übernahme auch ein vorgezogener kohle
ausstieg im übrigen kostet uns
milliarden über liebe dann
ehrlicherweise sprechen können wir uns
das jetzt leisten oder nicht aber wir
finden jetzt auch im haushalt maßnahmen
immer ehrlich sind finden wir sie
überall wo wir sagen können da könnten
wir jetzt auch noch geld einsammeln und
ich glaube bevor wir über eine
steuererhöhung sprechen das wissen wir
alle wir sind haben eine schwächelnde
konjunktur das wäre gift wenn wir sie
machen würden insofern wäre das auch für
mich das letzte instrument dann wäre ich
auch erst bereit ehrlich auch mit der
regierung mit der opposition zusammen
setzen und sagen wo können wir da noch
ein paar punkte finden und für
haushälter glauben sie uns wir finden
will ist es realistisch zu glauben dass
diese schuldenbremse nächstes jahr schon
wieder stattfindet oder wird sie noch
länger ausgesetzt seien
also es muss gelingen und der
haushaltsplan der mittelfristigen
finanzplanung sagt ja auch dass es
gelingen soll zudem zahlen wir haben in
diesem jahr erst mal laut plan eine
neuverschuldung von ca 100 milliarden
euro und die würde am sinken auf 7,5
milliarden euro das schafft der
bundesfinanzminister einerseits sind
immer auch alte rücklagen abbaut es gibt
immer noch eine asyl rücklage im
bundeshaushalt von knapp 50 milliarden
euro das kann auch schneller abbauen und
darüber hinaus machen wir uns nichts vor
die schuldenbremse ist ja jetzt schon
etwas geschlossen worden das heißt die
tilgungsverpflichtungen die die große
koalition in der letzten
legislaturperiode festgelegt hat die
neue ampel regierung noch einmal nach
hinten verschoben damit wird ein polster
geschafft von 50 milliarden euro wäre
die gesamte legislaturperiode also da
hat man sich schon gewisse spielräume
erkauft mir geht es einfach darum dass
die schuldenbremse eingehalten werden
muss weil wir ein momentum brauchen auch
innerhalb der politik wo wir einfach
sagen müssen wir können uns nicht weiter
kaputt verschulden und jeder
haushaltspolitiker opfer fallen in jeder
ausgabe politiker hat denn eine
verfassungsmäßige grenze an der sich
orientieren kann und deswegen sind wir
einfach fan der schuldenbremse wir
brauchen sie auch bei viel ökonomischer
kritik aber am ende ist es menschen
gemacht und es menschelt dann sehr im
bundestag und jeder hat wichtige und
sehr prioritäre projekte und deswegen
muss die schuldenbremse wieder herhalten
damit wir am ende auch maß und mitte
finden freimann jetzt gibt es ja auch
leute die gerne heilige kühe schlachten
es gibt ja auch die meinungen die
schuldenbremse sollte man eigentlich
nicht weiterführen sollte man wieder
abschaffen weil es macht keinen sinn die
immer so vor sich her zu tragen und sie
doch nicht einzuhalten was wie sollte
man mit diesem jahr in der verfassung
verankerten element umgehen
na ja also ich meine der saubere weg
wäre natürlich die schuldenbremse wieder
abzuschaffen ich war schon 2011 der
meinung dass das der völlig falsche weg
ist aber das wäre eine
grundgesetzänderung man müsste die
schuldenbremse also im bundestag und im
bundesrat mit zwei dritteln dann wieder
raus kegeln und das ist wahrscheinlich
nicht möglich weil ich jetzt mal
annehmen dass die fdp und die cdu hut
sie sitzen ja beide hier dem nicht
zustimmen würden insofern hat man jetzt
das problem dass immer wenn man
außerordentliche belastungen hat muss
man dann punktuell das grundgesetz dann
anpassen das passiert soll ja jetzt
passieren auch für dieses 100 milliarden
sondertopf für die bundeswehr
märz auch schon gesagt dass er zustimmen
wird wenn bestimmte bedingungen erfüllt
sind ja und das wird so der weg sei
nicht dass man immer ständig an dieser
bundes und bremse rum bastelt wenn man
jetzt mal sich fragt was bis wann kann
ein staat sich verschulden und ab wann
wird es gefährlich dann gibt es
eigentlich nur eine grenze und das ist
dass die inflation außer kontrolle gerät
das ist im augenblick in deutschland
noch nicht der fall das ist jetzt
vielleicht eine etwas erstaunliche
aussage weil ja die gemessene inflation
bei fünf prozent liegt aber es liegt ja
nur an den energiepreisen die wir nicht
beeinflussen können das machen die
ölscheichs oder das macht putin die
eigentliche kerninflation also das was
in deutschland an inflation entsteht
selbst ist noch nicht gefährlich da muss
man darauf achten nicht wenn man
feststellt dass man in so eine lohn
preis spirale gerät dann kann man sich
als staat nicht mehr weiter verschulden
allerdings ist das im augenblick noch
nicht in sicht weil die tariflöhne immer
noch moderat steigen die sind im letzten
jahr um 1,7 prozent gestiegen das ist
also irgendwie ganz ungefährlich aber
das muss man im blick behalten ansonsten
kann sich ein staat erstmal gefahrlos
verschulden um die aufgaben zu widmen
die anstehen und es bestreitet ja
niemand dass wir die ukraine flüchtlinge
aufnehmen dass wir eine energiewende
finanzieren müssen und so weiter
ich möchte ein aspekt entgegnen also all
ihre aussage ist richtig auch wir würden
jetzt eine auflösung der schuldenbremse
sicherlich nicht zustimmen an der stelle
aber in ihrer argumentation und dass das
vermisse ich meine argumentation wir
sind ja nicht isoliert wir sind in einem
finanz und wirtschaftssystem jahren von
europa und wir haben ja gesehen was in
einigen südländern passiert ist und wie
schwierig und hoch der an
konsolidierungsdruck in diesen ländern
gewesen ist bis die jetzt so
einigermaßen wieder kommen vorzeitig
auch kredite zurückzahlen das hat ja
viel auch in diesen volkswirtschaften
gemacht so und wir kennen die diskussion
auf der europäischen ebene von italien
von frankreich die sagen wir wollen die
schuldenregel noch auf europäischer
ebene auflösen so und und wenn wir jetzt
die wir als hort der solidität irgendwo
in europa gelten jetzt so leichtfertig
über neue schulden so leichtfertig über
eine auflösung der schuldenbremse regeln
werden dann halten wir das in europa
nicht aus dann wird es einen dammbruch
geben und dann weiß ich nicht was im
augen gesamten europäischen system
passiert und dass diese dimensionen
dürfen wir einfach nicht vergessen dass
überrollt unsere volkswirtschaft dann in
ihren auswirkungen da bin ich mir
relativ sicher
es gibt muss ja auch jemand der
herr da muss
ja das ist was wir mal sagt er
beschreibt es natürlich richtig und auch
sauber aus dem lehrbuch aber wenn man
das sich in griechenland damals
angeschaut hat dann gibt es durchaus
grenzen die man auch an diese
berücksichtigen sollte und wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass wir ökonomisch in
einer sehr komplizierten situation sind
die auch eben der krieg in europa
herbeigeführt hat und ich gehe davon aus
dass der schuldendienst also die zinsen
steigen und dann hat der bundeshaushalt
schon probleme also zum vergleich
zurzeit müssen wir unsere bundesschuld
die ungefähr bei 1,3 billionen euro
liegt mit vier milliarden euro zinsen im
jahr bedienen vor zehn zwölf jahren war
die summe lag sie bei 32 milliarden euro
und war eine der grössten
haushaltspositionen die wir hatten also
wenn es eine zinswende gibt dann haben
wir natürlich auch extreme probleme
mittelfristig im bundeshaushalt insofern
ist da schon eine natürliche grenze und
wir haben natürlich auch politische
grenzen die wir einhalten sollen dass 60
prozent ziel ist aus meiner sicht
weiterhin richtig um eine gewisse
stabilität zu haben und da sollten wir
nicht gleichzeitig das aufgeben und am
ende wir haben natürlich immer die
möglichkeit mit sondervermögen dagegen
zu angehen ich halte das für falsch weil
ein sondervermögen und darüber reden die
ja auch gleich ein wenig den fokus des
gesamthaushaltes träsch per und deswegen
müssen wir mal das gesamtkonstrukt auch
sehen und vor dem hintergrund gehören
alle schulden die der bund macht ob im
sondervermögen oder in den sogenannten
kernhaushalten auch tage stellt und
transparent gemacht deswegen ist die
schuldenbremse auch vor dem hintergrund
der transparenz aus meiner sicht sehr
wichtig vorher man vielleicht ganz kurz
noch wenn sie dann kommen wir nicht
tatsächlich zum sondervermögen
ja ich will nur sagen dass es nicht
möglich ist deutschland mit griechenland
zu vergleichen es ist richtig
griechenland war 2010 überschuldet und
zwar deswegen weil es hoffnungslos im
ausland verschuldet war also griechen
hat hat immer viel zu viel importiert
und so wenig exportiert so dass es ja
nun ganz und gar nicht die situation die
wir in deutschland haben sondern jeder
weiß dass deutschland permanent
exportüberschüsse produziert in
unglaublichem ausmaß das heißt wir sind
überhaupt nicht im ausland verschuldet
sondern im gegenteil das heißt wir
deutschen können uns das erlauben
schulden zu machen und das sollten wir
dann auch nutzen wenn es gute gründe
gibt schulden aufzunehmen ich bin ja
nicht dafür dass man das einfach
schulden macht aber ukraine krise
klimawandel
kroner das waren alles wirklich gute
gründe und da sollte man jetzt nicht
sich irgendwie beschränken nach dem
motto wir könnten griechenland werden
das werden wir nie und nimmer seien gut
die sg zum schuldenmachen obwohl ja das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr von
100 milliarden euro gar keine schulden
sind sind die außerhalb der
schuldenbremse und außerhalb des
haushalts sind natürlich in wirklichkeit
beschuldigen ist aber eine schuld
ermächtigung sind noch keine schule noch
keine schulden aber eine schuld
ermächtigung da gibt es glaube ich
keinen tilgungsplan dass mit der von
ihnen auch
wenn man eins gesetzt haben war da haben
wir einige dauerhafte belastung jetzt
sozusagen noch einen sonderfall neben
all den belastungen die wir schon haben
auch noch diese sondervermögen das wie
gesagt nicht so ganz klar ist wir reden
gleich noch über die details aber wie
das überhaupt getätigt werden sollen 100
milliarden ist ja auch kein pappenstiel
doch wir werden wenn wir in den
gesetzentwurf gucken so wie er
gegenwärtig jetzt vorliegt dann werden
wir sehen dass zu der frage der tilgung
auch die entsprechenden hinweise in dem
gesetzentwurf sind nicht in der
verfassung an der stelle aber sie sind
in dem gesetzentwurf trägt und so wie
ich die cdu verstanden habe ist das für
sie auch eine conditio sine qua non und
ich halte es auch für richtig und ich
bin da auch beim holznagel es ist
wichtig dass so etwas transparent
gemacht wird die fragen dass wir da mehr
tun müssten hat eine einhellige mehrheit
bis auf die linke die dagegen es aus
traditionellen gründen die gesagt wird
wir müssen hier nachholen weil alle
regierungen vorher egal wer daran
beteiligt war gedacht hat es gäbe diese
friedensdividende übrigens deswegen weil
den menschen das müssen wir auch ehrlich
sagen immer hoffen dass es gut geht weil
das ist ein fehler natürlich aber leider
wenn die die die maler sind werden oft
dann als falsche propheten bezeichnet
das ist jetzt eine lösung die notwendig
ist um eine andere verpflichtung zwei
prozent ziel zu erfolgen obwohl ich mit
prozent setzen immer meine
schwierigkeiten hat weil das ist keine
echte haushaltspolitik sondern das ist
so eine gute show an die wand gestellt
aber diese verknüpfung ist jetzt wichtig
von den 100 milliarden mit dem erreichen
des zwei prozent sieht zudem die
international uns verpflichtet haben
heute gabs ja ein putziges 10 im
bundestag ein wortgefecht zwischen
frauen schlafzimmerwand von ihrer
fraktion der kurzen des
verteidigungsausschusses und den
fraktionsvorsitzenden ihrer fraktion wer
eigentlich für das abtauchen der
bundeswehr verantwortlich ist
habe ich schwarz für 2009 bis 2013 da
waren sie glaube ich schon im bundestag
gewesen habe ich da irgendwie raus
gehört war nicht so ganz gut zuhören
akustisch doch jetzt wird im saal schon
okay und ich habe es nicht einmal
angehört jetzt jedenfalls ist man der
meinung die bundeswehr muss richtig gut
ausgestattet werden jetzt gibt es von
ihrer fraktion schon den verdacht diese
100 milliarden gehen gar nicht an die
bundeswehr sondern an etwas was im
weitesten sinne mit sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik zu tun hat dieser
eine zusatz das ist der den
streitkräften zu kommen soll solf
wunsch der bündnisgrünen wieder
herausgestrichen worden sein bei dieser
vorlage für das sondervermögen das ist
ja eine verfassungsänderung bleibt es
dabei dass sie nur mitgehen und
unterschreiben wenn tatsächlich diese
100 milliarden von vorne bis hinten auf
heller und pfennig wie man früher gesagt
hat jeden cent der bundeswehr zu gute
kommen na ja also das was im
sondervermögen drin ist und das ist mein
verständnis eines sondervermögens sonst
können wir das im haushalt darstellen
das muss über jährige große
rüstungsprojekte beinhalten die gibt es
die liste ist ja jetzt nicht irgendwie
aus der luft gegriffen auch die summe
ist nicht auf der aus der luft gegriffen
dahinter steckt ja ein ein
fähigkeitsprofil an der stelle und wenn
wir das jetzt nicht über das
sondervermögen abbilden dann bleibt da
was über also da müssen wir uns fragen
wie machen wir uns dann mit der
fähigkeit nehmen wir denn die aus dem
normalen haushalt und insofern glaube
ich heute wurde über neue sicherheits
begriffe gesprochen glaube kollege
karsten klein hat dazu was gesagt die
grünen haben wir etwas zugesagt ja ein
etwas erweiterten sicherheitsbegriff der
nicht nur im bereich der verteidigung in
den blick nimmt sondern auch die
außenbeziehungen in den blick nimmt den
katastrophenschutz mit einbezieht den
darf man ja durchaus vertreten der ist
ja auch nicht inhaltlich ganz von der
hand zu weisen nur wir sind der
auffassung das gehört nicht in
sondervermögen diese mittel gehören in
den kernhaushalt denn ich sehe schon die
gefahr wir sind bereit immer mehr aus
diesem kernhaushalt rauszunehmen und in
sondervermögen reinzuschieben und
deswegen sage ich es muss befristet sein
es muss klar sein welche projekte da
drin sind und dann können wir uns glaube
ich da auch mit der regierung darüber
verständigen wir sehen da halt nur
projekte die tatsächlich für jetzt die
einsatzfähigkeit der bundeswehr gegeben
diese 100 milliarden ausschließlich in
rüstungsaufträge also ich sehe das von
der frage was im gesetz stehen wird
nämlich die frage beschaffungen
anschaffungen das zweite aber da muss
ich ja den kollegen hasen auf einen
widerspruch hinweisen die cdu/csu hat
immer gesagt und das recht und ich hab
es auch heute im plenum noch mal gesagt
sie möchte dass das zwei prozent ziel
erreicht wird dann muss ich aber auch
sagen wenn der bundeskanzler gesagt hat
wir machen 100 milliarden applaus
applaus nächster satz wir werden das
zwei prozent ziel erreichen dann müssen
die 100 milliarden für das zwei prozent
ziel sein und wenn sie für das zwei
prozent ziel sein müssen dann gelten die
regeln der nato was unter das zwei
prozent ziel gehört und war daran
besonders schön längst hätte machen
müssen insofern sind diese 100
milliarden euro diese 100 milliarden
euro eigentlich ja nicht wirklich ein
zuwachs in diese zwei prozent vom
bruttoinlandsprodukt sich jetzt schon
längst geben müssen da ist das mitgefühl
des wegen dieser forderung der nato
verrechnet also ist es nicht wirklich
eine zusätzliche auf wo sie mehr
nennenswert erstens ist es eine
zusätzliche ausrüstung der bundeswehr
weil wir insbesondere bei der frage der
beschaffung altes durch neues ersetzt
tornados konstruiert in den 60ern baut
in den 70er 80er setzen wir jetzt zum
beispiel durch eine sms dass die erste
beschaffen dann gibt das zweite ist noch
mal bei dem zwei prozent ziel bisher
haben glaube ich ich glaube zehn prozent
der nato statt fünf stück haben dieses 2
prozent ziel erreicht und bei der frage
was sie da rein rechnen können kann man
viel reden nein dieses ziel ist ein ziel
das wir erreichen wollen es ist keine
einklagbaren fliegt und dafür diente
neben das auffüllen des
verteidigungshaushalt der ungefähr bei
50 milliarden bisher ist hoch auch wenn
man so will 70 milliarden und damit
komme ich in die nähe der zwei prozent
da kann sich aber im kernhaushalt wenn
das bibb sich verändert auch noch mal
was verändert entscheidend ist für mich
ebenfalls der ich sage ich will den
internationalen vertrag einhalten ich
muss ausgaben aus dem 100 milliarden
machen die unter diese zwei prozent
fallen denn nur so kann ich das dann
auch erreichen was im kernhaushalt da
noch alles dazugehört ist was an die 100
milliarden euro sind wir bei manchen vor
allen dingen auf der politisch linken
seite frei man durchaus umstritten bei
spd und bündnisgrünen ist das ein
trostpflaster dass man sagt doppelt so
viel kohle wandert in den klimaschutz
200 milliarden sind ja dafür jetzt
angesetzt bis 2026 ist das etwas womit
dann die ampel koalition ganz gut
agieren kann und auch innere konflikte
damit etwas klein halten kann
also mein eindruck ist dass die
allermeisten
mitglieder auch bei den grünen und auch
bei der spd gemerkt haben das ist diese
friedensdividende von der herr fricke ja
zu recht gesprochen hat einfach nicht
gibt wir hatten die idee europa ist
befriedet es gibt hier keine kriege mehr
und dann haben sich natürlich alle
gefragt ja warum sollen wir denn die
bundeswehr ausrüsten wenn doch hier
eigentlich nur frieden herrscht so das
war auch die haltung bei den grünen das
war die hälfte haltung aber eben auch
bei der fdp der cdu ich glaube das hat
sich in den einzelnen parteien überhaupt
nicht unterschieden so und jetzt sind
aber auch alle grünen und auch
eigentlich alle in der spd komplett
aufgewacht mit wenigen ausnahmen ich
sage dann gerhard schröder aber der rest
ist ja jetzt
total schockiert und
ist bereit geld auszugeben
jetzt ist natürlich die frage wie man
die zukunft sieht das ist ja sehr
unterschiedlich also meine position wäre
zum beispiel rein ökonomisch dass
russland diese ukraine krieg nicht lange
durchhalten kann rein ökonomisch ich
sage dazu nichts elitäres strategisch
aber das ist keine katastrophe dieser
extrem teure krieg für so eine arme
wirtschaft deswegen würde ich denken
dass krieg irgendwann erstens zu ende
geht und zweitens dass russland danach
derartig zerstört ist rein ökonomisch
dass es nicht so schnell in der lage ist
einen neuen krieg zu stark man dann
sogar abrüstungsgespräche haben wird
aber vielleicht ist das alles nur
solange sie viel hoffnung auf jeden fall
bis man dieses abrüstungsgespräche hat
muss man leider als erstmal in die
militär ausrüstung investieren ich
befinde am ende der sendung heraus war
kurz noch diese sondervermögen wird das
möglicherweise schule machen denn es
gibt ja noch ganz andere projekte und
vorstellungen vielleicht anforderungen
auch dinge an die wir noch gar nicht
denken glauben sie dass das jetzt
häufiger vorkommen wird dass man
jenseits von haushalt und schuldenbremse
mit sondervermögen arbeitet
also zur wahrheit gehört dass wir schon
jetzt 26 sondervermögen haben mit einem
gesamtwert von 130 milliarden euro wenn
jetzt die fluthilfe noch hinzu kommen
als sondervermögen und die bundeswehr
dann werden wir 28 sondervermögen haben
mit weit über 230 milliarden euro daran
sieht man schon mal das hat schon in der
vergangenheit schule gemacht und ich
befürchte einfach dass man ein
sondervermögen temporäre diskussions
spitzen abbaut dann schickt man das
alles rüber und sagt jetzt haben wir das
thema erledigt und mitnichten ist das
thema erledigt grundsätzlich auch zum
ziel sage ich ich fand das ziel immer
schon etwas fragwürdig weil die zwei
prozent schaffen wir auch in dem wir
tausendmal abbauen insofern ist es auch
ein stückweit steuergeldverschwendung
was wir in den letzten jahren bei der
bundeswehr erlebt haben und vor dem
hintergrund finde ich es auch in ordnung
dass man jetzt geld in die hand nimmt
und die bundeswehr zudem ertüchtigt was
sie eigentlich auch darstellen soll also
das ist völlig in ordnung aber das muss
eben einhergehen mit reformen mit
beschaffungsmanagement und auch mit den
zielen ich bin auch ein bisschen
europäisch und ich denke man muss sich
auch innerhalb der nato mal darüber
verständigen welche armee was kann wir
sollten nicht trug anliegen das alles
die bundeswehr krank oder sollen wir
müssen und sie spezialisiert
jetzt kommen wir schon in sechs thema
wie sieht die militär planung aus
zumindestens haben sie jetzt mit ihren
hinweis auf die sondervermögen die frage
der sendung schon beantwortet woher das
geld eigentlich kommt möglicherweise
ausgehen sondervermögen ich bedanke mich
bei otto fricke ich bedanke mich bei
herrn hase bei und ricke herrmann und
bei reiner holznagel zuschauer morgen in
der phoenix runde nato gipfel in brüssel
die nato und putins krieg aufrüsten
stadt einmischen jetzt findet der tag
mit thomas bade und da gibt es noch mal
ausführlich um die heutige
generaldebatte im bundestag bleiben sie
bei uns
[Musik]